[Music]
tell me when to sleep
go ahead all right uh slate
actually i don't have milk in my
apartment mostly because
dear and me are not sympatic darry and
me
not symptom to the do you think that we
could afford an apartment with
yup hola
we need your biggest races just what the
[ __ ] what can i say hola
we need your biggest i have the ultimate
plan to win like hearts
and sciences that was like all the
camera
i wish you would replace my mother
because then you wouldn't even be here
hey
the hell has gotten into you
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he's very lucky
dude either she's making the eggplant
parmesan or you're getting lucky this
friday
[Music]
i don't think she knows how to make
eight points
what should i say
oh my god grilled cheese
yeah now the party the phone my
dairy and i are not cyclical
i'm so so sorry simpatico
simcatico i'm never gonna live this down
i raised him to be true to himself and
to
stand up for those he kisses now
[Music]
who drinking
is it dreaming drinking about you and me
it's dreaming oh that's not the part i'm
supposed to say the line and then make
i was like oh you're so cute making that
face to me
we should probably eat these before they
get cold
just old-fashioned
we should probably eat these before it
gets cold oh my gosh
[Music]
thank you i did i'm a child
not an animal
the lobster was everything we didn't
have lobsters
[Music]
that means i have 10 victory points
which would crown
me king of katan
okay who's ready to start playing
yeah my dad alberto what did he put this
thing together with
paperclips hey do you think we could
catch the end of the show
i think one
is not my synthetic
i'm a hollywood director now
[Music]
you